britney spears is ready for her comeback
oh yeah i would say a source tells et
that the 40 year old pop star is quote
actively eyeing different brand deals
and entertainment opportunities adding
that several companies have reached out
to her with offers and nothing is off
the table it's fun for me
she's excited to put her business woman
hat on in the new year and explore
different ventures that weren't
available to her in the past brittany is
her own decision maker now and she wants
to expand her professional horizons
she's just waiting for the right time
for everything i've been in the
conservatorship for 13 years
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in of
course last month a los angeles judge
ruled to terminate the conservatorship
that has controlled the pop star's life
career and finances for 13 years what's
next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person
brittany
and seems britt might be getting back to
her musical roots too last week the
songbird shared this clip to instagram
belting out some high notes and vocal
drills in her bathroom mirror i want you
to know just what
i
mean
and in the since deleted caption brit
teases quote
new song in the works
[Music]
as for her relationship with fiance sam
askari e.t source says he is a huge
support for brit and is encouraging her
in every way she inspires me quote
things are going very smooth and steady
for them as a couple and if anything
their relationship is even stronger
since getting engaged she's doing great
i'm great i'm just it's the happiest
time of our lives and we're just
enjoying it e.t chatted with brits man
last month and he teased what's next for
them you already know everyone knows
already sooner or later sooner or later
what a wedding
when do you want it to be sooner or
later yeah what kind of wedding do you
want to have what's your dream day you
know it's up to her she's wearing the
pants now
[Laughter]
finally right yeah of course the
lovebirds got engaged in september after
nearly five years of dating
you like it yeah
but sam told et back in 2019 that he
knew brit was the one you see marriage
in the future i mean absolutely this is
something that every couple should do
that's the whole point of a relationship
we're a family and the 27 year old model
actor has been right by brit's side as
she fought to break free from her
conservatorship could you give me one
word to describe how are you both
feeling amazing earlier this month sam
helped the lucky singer ring in her
milestone 40th birthday happy birthday
to you oh my god
it's beautiful
at the time a source told et he wanted
to make a quote huge splash for her big
day and planned to go over the top to
make sure the pop star felt important
appreciated and loved oh my god thank
you so much everybody cover your ears
happy birthday
this is not from me but
baby this is i'm gonna take credit for
this as for brit a source previously
told et that this was the first time in
a very long time that the grammy winner
felt like she had a reason to celebrate
her birthday quote she is finally living
and enjoying life along with all the new
experiences it has to offer